good afternoon everybody and welcome
back to a little MLB the show 17
baseball coverage here on gamespot I'm
here with Ramon Russell we're going to
be chatting about franchise
yes franchise mode so let's get right
into it all right so first thing you see
here is when you come into franchise
mode things are a little different we're
always trying to make the game more
accessible and easy to get into and
that's what you see here for franchise
no responsibilities before you get into
the game all this stuff used to be
hitting the menus now it's at the
forefront so you can decide from the
word go hey if you want to control
everything you can do that or if you
know you just want to focus on playing
the game and have everything else at the
auto you can do that as well and that's
in the front end also do you want to
play spring spring training or not you
can skip that and jump right into the
regular season so we're going to talk
about two real big features off a
franchise mode the first one is called
critical situations right here which you
can turn off if you want it to the other
one is called franchise mode
front-office so we're going to turn
critical situations off first and we're
going to go down to this game critical
is that how would you describe that oh I
will tell you everything about critical
situations
all right so let's actually Sam is this
so this is the brand new franchise mode
launch pad play game that's always been
there it's a 45 minute experience that's
what you've come to know and love and
email be the show then we have player
lock player lock is a way for you to
have that road to show experience but in
franchise mode when you lock on to your
favorite player no matter who it is
Anthony Rizzo or Hunter Pence or whoever
and you just play the at-bats the
pitching or the fielding opportunities
right there are involved in that's a
10-minute game experience then we have
manage full game here this is for this
is all about strategy kind of like you
know civilization if you just want to
manage the every single detail of the
game you're going to manage only moulton
you don't play you just manage you make
every single decision right and that's
about the same
I was playing a full game the new mode
here is called quick manage first thing
you notice quick manage is a five minute
experience so we're gonna jump in too
quick manage you could essentially burn
through the season pretty oh you can get
through the season pretty quickly and so
everything we're doing in franchise mode
with franchise for an office quick
manage and critical situations which I
elaborate on in a minute is people want
to play franchise mode but they don't
want to sim everything but I want to be
feel like they're involved and the
decisions that they're making is having
an impact on stats and getting to the
playoffs drafting and all that so we're
in quick manage every press of X is in
that back but you also have options so
now we're here with pitching so we're
still swinging so every time I press X
if they full that bad and you can
simulate a half inning so in like 10
seconds you know we're at the fourth
inning and you can continue to pitch I
can pitch the contact to try to get this
double play and it's so simple but you
can still see you have control over
everything everyone you still need to do
a pitching changes you can still do
substitutions oh that's a solo hold on
so what really makes quick manage really
awesome is if we get to a situation that
we want to get into okay so now we got
we got a man on first I want to play
that so we hit square and now we'll jump
into the game in that situation and
we'll play it and then I'll show you the
next really cool thing about quick
manage right so this is anytime you want
to jump in whether it's a pitching such
it could be at any situation you could
jump into the game and start playing
let's grant so one of the bases loaded
you don't wanna ya if any bases loaded
and you don't want to give it up [ __ ] up
the chance you jump right in so here we
go here we can open this game up we got
a man on first no outs Oh safe it out
Yankee Stadium looks great by the way
here we go let's just not hit into a
double play
oh nice pitch I love it you can see the
subway in the back feel like I'm there
yeah stadium art is trying to get every
little detail alright so you can get a
ball up in the air just not hitting to
this double play oh you got me you got
them all right so let's say I don't want
to play this that back with Chris Carter
I can go down here hit pause and now I'm
right back into quick manage and what's
really awesome is the game still back
there and because we're already in let's
say I wanted to get in here
I hit circled in the game and bam I'm
right back into the game so once we load
in once you don't have to load in again
so we'll do this at-bat
see if we can get another run no love
deity pop-up but he's no he's no Derek
Jeter and again we can jump right back
even the Nimitz even in the middle of
that bat you can jump right back in and
that's the game and we were able to play
that game in a few events in a little
over five minutes and that's what makes
quick manage so awesome it allows you to
play so much more baseball in a short
amount of time sometimes you just want
to sit there and play a full dining
experience yep
other times you may only have 10 minutes
you come in here and knock out a few
games and obviously in the manege mode
it'll vary on time you know saying I
want to fat this one I want to bet this
when I pitch here back there so it could
take longer than five minutes
it could sure I can take basically as
long as you want it to take so now we're
going to talk about critical situation
so we just turn that back on
so what critical situations allows you
to do is still be involved when you're
siming chunks of time right so we want a
sim a month here so if the game finds
any late inning situation that it deems
critical it's going to stop and ask us
if you want to play it right and so
let's sim let's see what we get
all right so critical game situation
Davis is trying to close it out let's
get a rally going so with the Yankees
this is a good time to jump into the
game so we're going to jump in at the
end of the game try to get the rally and
win right and now it'll automatically
tell you when these critical your
helmets are occurring yes they only pop
up in late any situations could be a
save it could be hey here's a chance to
tie it
it could be Oh so-and-so has three home
runs think you can get that for four
right and now if you wanted to skip the
critical mode you could just you can you
can turn it off it's a toggle so you
don't have to skip anything if you don't
want to right Oh get through now we're
in business
oh wow in business pitching change
immediately
[Applause]
there you go all we got to do is not hit
into a double playing with fine it alone
ain't it Wrigley Oh was almost mope that
one I notice the cleats are some of them
are branded now yeah we have more
licensed equipment we've been adding new
license equipment every few years and
we've added a a handful of new brands
this year shoes bat tape new bats a few
new gloves yeah oh I thought I had that
one alright okay
all right here we go started two outs
after coming back to his old his old
stomping ground there let's go in the
gap in the gap seeing those new ball
physics puts it in him all the way home
we're gonna test that arm we're gonna
test that arm
oh we tested that arm right and that's
how we tested that arm geez who is that
all right well at least we tied it up
and then again if we if we want to we
can jump back into quick manage right Oh
and bam and that's what's so awesome so
you can do critical situations and quick
manage and player like if I wanted to I
could go back into the game and declare
like so all of those ecosystems work
well with all each other in the same
environment they all exist and the
Yankees won that game and that's
critical situations will sim will sim
one more to see what pops up awesome I
feel like this is a much more
streamlined yes than ever before
everything that we focused on that Luis
Martinez and Daniel the programmer
focused on this year was giving you
different ways to be involved in
franchise multi-plate more games without
having to spend a lot of times because
people just they just don't want to see
them they want to be involved and that's
what critical situations and franchise
for an office allows you to do and
here's this exact situation I just
mentioned got an opportunity here to get
that third home run so we're gonna put
you on the spot let's see what you can
do you I mean the Yankees is your team
powers still square power swing is still
square oh my god I got faith in you I
don't know I don't know being a little
nervous a little nervous but it feels
good to control my team I'm hoping they
have a good season this year it's gonna
be interesting it should be got the farm
system is looking real nice right about
now about a lot of young players all
right here we go just looking for that
third home run also Cincinnati
what a fantastic nope no reticle on hey
you know what I put it in play you put
it in play hyper implies didn't play and
that's franchise mobile front office and
critical situations well thank you so
much again Ramon it's been fantastic
having you we're all really looking
forward to franchise mode so thank you
so much and take care